DC had high hopes for "Blue Beetle."
So why did it suffer the same fate
as "Shazam! Fury of the Gods" and bomb big
time? Turns out that timing is everything.
Despite getting mostly positive reviews from
critics and audiences alike, DC's latest effort,
"Blue Beetle," ended up flopping at the
box office. While "Blue Beetle" did kick
"Barbie" out of the top spot at the box office
after it spent a whopping four weeks there,
the film only earned around $25 million. So
what kept "Blue Beetle" from being so buzzy,
and why didn't it perform nearly
as well as the studio executives at
DC and Warner Bros. likely hoped? It
probably came down to a few factors.
For one, August is a tough month to release a
huge movie. TV Tropes calls it a "dump month,"
and the back half of the month is usually
reserved for movies that aren't expected to
perform quite as well, seeing as everybody
is wrapping up their summer fun. Kids are
heading back to school or families
are taking one last trip together,
so the big releases are typically
preserved for the holiday season.
There are, of course, exceptions to this rule.
"Guardians of the Galaxy" was released in August
of 2014 and became an immediate hit, and like
"Blue Beetle," it was also the origin story
of comic book characters that had largely been
forgotten except by the most ardent of readers.
So what was the difference here? Part of
it comes down to the marketing campaign,
a dearth of major movie stars, and
some very, very unfortunate timing.
"Where did you go?"
"Mama! I don't know. I think I cut a bus in half."
"Blue Beetle" was always a risky movie, too.
The film is based on a lesser-known character
whose cast doesn't boast any enormous names,
with the biggest being Susan Sarandon. It's
all frustrating because Xolo Maridueña has
earned praise for his central performance as
Jaime Reyes, but while he's a fan favorite
on "Cobra Kai", he's not yet a huge star.
Marvel was able to get away with casting people
like Tom Hiddleston and Chris Hemsworth before
they became two of the world's biggest stars.
However, for a movie to face off against
star-studded flicks like "Barbie," you might need
to pack a punch slightly bigger with the casting.
"Blue Beetle" also didn't wage the biggest
marketing campaign. To bring "Barbie" into
it again, that movie was simply inescapable
this summer, while the average moviegoer
probably wasn't even sure "Blue Beetle"
was coming out. There's another issue here,
though. "Blue Beetle" simply couldn't have a
huge press tour to put its stars on the map,
because of the current double strike between
SAG-AFTRA and the WGA against major studios.
In order to avoid crossing the picket line,
stars can't do any publicity for past,
present, or future projects. And
while the stars of "Blue Beetle"
have stood strong with SAG-AFTRA and are
also fighting for fair pay and treatment,
it can't be overlooked that their timing was
absolutely terrible when it came to publicity.
Frankly, DC hasn't been doing
themselves any favors as of late,
either. "Shazam! Fury of the Gods" was
a huge flop when it came out in March,
and despite star Zachary Levi's complaints
that nobody's making quality content anymore,
that unloved movie certainly contributed to
superhero fatigue. As Marvel moves away from
the one-two punch of "Avengers: Infinity War"
and "Endgame" and DC struggles to keep up, the
world has gotten more and more projects that have
only produced diminishing returns. Things felt
especially dire for DC when "The Flash," released
in the middle of June, became one of Warner Bros.'
biggest box office bombs. So in a way, it
feels like "Blue Beetle" was set up to fail.
"You're the Blue Beetle."
"I could use that arsenal right about now."
The truth is that, despite repeatedly strapping
on their wax wings and heading in the sun's
direction, DC hasn't yet reached Marvel's heights.
So "Blue Beetle" is another casualty, which is
really a shame. A film that put a spotlight on
Latino people and introduced fresh faces into the
media landscape is a net positive, so hopefully,
more people will discover "Blue Beetle" with time.